Michael Keaton's Batman officially returns in
"The Flash." We've known about it for a while,
but actually getting to see him on screen again
has set the Internet wild with excitement.
Here's what everybody online had to say.
The highly anticipated Super Bowl
LVII trailer for "The Flash" got fans
buzzing before the big game on Sunday. The
blockbuster tease presented the anxious DC
fandom with several jaw-dropping revelations
and eye-opening little details. As a result,
the fans have a fair share of things to be
excited about when the film drops in June.
During the trailer, not one, but two Barry
Allens unite to try and undo the damage done
when the Flash breaks the Speed Force, causing
an existential meltdown across timelines.
Newcomer Supergirl and a returning
General Zod have their moments,
but it's Michael Keaton's return as Batman
that really put this trailer over the top.
Keaton reprises the dual roles
of billionaire Bruce Wayne and
the Dark Knight detective he originally
portrayed in Tim Burton's 1989 "Batman."
"Yeah. I'm Batman."
For Keaton, it's been nearly 35 years since
he first suited up to fight crime in Gotham
City. But returning to the role and putting
the Batsuit back on after all these years
was easier than fans might think. In an
interview with "Jake's Takes" Keaton said,
"It was shockingly normal — weird. And
like I went, 'Oh, oh yeah, that's right.'"
The return of Keaton's Batman is arguably the
high-water mark for "The Flash" despite all of
its cool characters, even the film's titular
star. And it seems the fans will accept almost
anything "The Flash" has to offer thanks
to Keaton's involvement in the project.
One YouTuber posted in the
comments of the new trailer:
"Seeing Michael Keaton as the
Dark Knight again after 34 years
just brought a tear to my eye.
This movie is going to be EPIC."
Keaton's crime-fighting Bruce Wayne last appeared
in 1992's "Batman Returns," which
was also helmed by Tim Burton,
and there's no denying that the DC fandom is
happy to have him back. Another commenter wrote:
"Not gonna lie. I got teary-eyed
seeing Michael Keaton back as Batman."
Keaton's version of the Dark
Knight seems like he's going
to be a major player in "The Flash,"
judging from the Super Bowl trailer,
and many of the fans are incredibly
grateful. Another YouTuber wrote,
"Words can't express how much it means to me to
see Michael Keaton back as Batman. Thank you."
Most of the chatter following "The Flash"
Super Bowl drop seems to be focused on the Bat,
so it shouldn't come as a surprise
that fans are willing to put up with
multiple Ezra Millers just to
see Keaton don the cowl again.
"It's my face. You stole my face."
One user on Twitter posted,
"I'm up for DC disappointing me again just to
watch Michael Keaton play Batman one more time."
And Miller may be playing the titular role, but
some fans will buy tickets for the sole purpose
of witnessing Keaton clad in the Batsuit
again. Composer Brian Ralston tweeted,
"I hope Warner Bros. Pictures
properly interprets that people
are going to see this film (and it will
be successful) because of Michael Keaton
returning to be Batman in it and not
because of Ezra Miller. Just saying."
For other fans, Miller's off-screen issues
might have kept them from watching "The Flash"
altogether had it not been for the inclusion
of Keaton's Batman. One Twitter user said,
"I was mad when they didn't pull this
movie because of all the actor was doing,
but I really want to see this. Especially
Michael Keaton, he's the best."
Hopefully, the hype surrounding Keaton's
return and the film will pay off come June.